Hello and welcome to the Software Freedom Podcast.
Dear listener, thank you so much for being here, for turning on the Software Freedom
Podcast and for also supporting the Free Software Foundation Europe.
This podcast is brought to you by the Free Software Foundation Europe and we are a charity
that empowers users to control technology.
Today I'm here with Carsten Agger, the FSFE's Danish Coordination.
Hello Carsten, it's so nice to finally have you here on the Software Freedom Podcast.
We have been trying to organize this for quite a while now.
Thank you so much for making the time, thank you so much for joining me.
Hello Bonnie and thanks for having me and yeah, it's unglazed, it's finally worked out.
Me too.
I think it was a month now that we tried to organize this right?
Yeah.
Very very happy that this worked out.
How did you start to become involved in the FSFE?
That was back around 2011 I think and the prehistory is that I discovered Free Software
like as a concept to engage myself in 2004, 2004, 2005 and I started writing a lot of
blog posts about it and I read whatever Richard Stallman had written about it and I started using
Ubuntu on my local computers at home and experimented with other distributions such as
Debian or something called TimeBurlig at the time and FreeBSD, that kind of thing.
But I got involved in doing advocacy for Ubuntu around 2009.
There was a guy in August who wanted to create what he would call, what he would call it
an Ubuntu user group or Ubuntu day or his idea was that we in August would meet once a month or so
and engage in the Ubuntu community.
So he was very focused on Ubuntu and I wanted some more activity around Free Software in the area so I joined in
and after a year of this we helped co-found the local hackerspace in August and when we switched to the
hackerspace from the local library, all of a sudden there were a lot fewer people attending our meeting
because the hackerspace was like fire away but it also turned out that this guy Martin's idea was
that we should be there like a supportive community, we should come and we should do book triaging,
we should do testing, we should do book reports, we should maybe code and send the input
to the Ubuntu community slash canonical.
But all the people who turned up actually were more interested in like tips and tricks
for my desktop and stuff which we were not very focused on.
So after some time we were four people at the time driving that Ubuntu group after some time and that was in 2011
I think Martin got triplets and another guy had to move to Copenhagen for a new job
and a third person, a woman, also got a new job and that meant I was the only one left to maybe run the group
Oh no!
Yeah and then I decided I'm not going to do this because I am not as such really interested in Ubuntu
I am more interested in Free Software as a concept and I need to think this over
so this was 2011
and around that time I started looking around for organized Free Software activities in Europe and I
of course knew about the FSF and I was also like a associate member I think they call it of the FSF
paying them some money every month and then I also discovered there was this thing called Free Software foundation
Europe, the FSFE and the FSFE had local groups in something called the fellowship of the FSFE
so I joined that I started an FSFE blog which still exists but isn't really updated very often
and then I started thinking about I could create a group which had local meetings
in order to take over from my activity in the Ubuntu group but this time focusing on the concept of Free Software
and the necessity of Free Software, the politics and policies behind Free Software
and in order to start doing that I contacted the FSFE as an organization
and at that time I got hold of the vice president of the FSFE who was called at the time Matsias Kirsner
and yeah same guy and he said he was very excited about me wanting to start this local group in Orhus
but he also wanted to check me out first so he wanted to have a phone call and we did that
and yeah and basically in early 2012 we started the weekly meetings in the Hagger Space
now they were at first monthly meetings in the Hagger Space
and I tried pulling people in, some of my colleagues, some people from the Hagger Space people
but you did not go back to the library right?
no I did not go back to the library we...
at the time there was this when we first moved the Ubuntu meetings out to the Hagger Space
the Hagger Space was like in an industrial neighborhood like far out a bit difficult to get
and later when in early 2012 the Hagger Space had moved to a location
very close to the computer science department of the university
so it had actually moved to a very good location
so that was why I didn't consider going back to the library at the time
but yeah we were running these monthly meetings from 2012 to 2015
and I was...
and as a result Matsias asked me if I wanted to officially be the coordinator for Denmark
and I did and I was actually also the only person doing any organized advocacy work at the time
there were of course quite some supporters as we call them today
fellows as we call them at the time in Denmark but I was the only one who was really active
so from... yeah from early 2012 we went on with a small break
because unfortunately later that year my eldest son died
so I had to take some time out but then we restarted in 2013
and had monthly meetings in the Hagger Space where it may be between two and twelve people
I'm very sorry for the last person
yeah thank you but yeah that was what it was but this went on until 2015
in 2015 I was a co-worker organized the official Libra office conference for that year 2015
my co-worker was or is very active in the Libra office community
and he wanted to organize that conference in office and he lives in Copenhagen and works in Copenhagen
so he asked if I wanted to be fit on the feet on the ground for that event
and I did and I involved the FSFA local group in that so it was like a collaborative effort
when we managed to mobilize quite a lot of voluntary effort to organize that conference
which was also good because in the end there was about
like that was about I think about eight thousand euros left of the official conference budget
and we used that estimation for Libra office Denmark for the Ubuntu Denmark thing
and we used them as donations for the local Hagger Space
so in that way our work with the conference also gave something back to the communities it came from
oh that's really nice yeah and but at that time I had moved on to some other interests
which were not Free Software and I was also seeing that whereas people were actually showing up
to our monthly meetings and whereas we actually had some good discussions going
and really achieved something I think with the Libra office conference I also saw that
I was the only person really driving it and if I stopped doing it it would not continue
and then I thought at the time I had plenty of other interests
I am not going to do this because I don't see a path to creating something that would continue after I stopped myself
so from the long term perspective basically was missing right
the long term perspective was missing because I didn't want to be like the only person driving it
so at that time in late 2015 I closed down the group and said well we achieved something with this conference
let's take a break and then instead for some years I was quite involved in like the European community
in a way there were a lot of discussions with what was at that time called the fellowship of the FSC
the fellowship of the FSC people did not really understand always what it was
what it meant, what it was supposed to be, what relationship it had to the FSC and at the time I thought that
it would be more logical to have like something as we call it now called local groups
closer associated with the FSC because there were a lot of discussions about that
and I took part of that and in the end that meant that in 2019 I think in 2018 actually
in 2018 I wrote to Matthias and said that I felt that even though I was not organizing the monthly meetings in August anymore
I still felt that I could contribute something to the FSC and I would actually like to be considered as a member of the GA
and that meant that I was invited to the GA in 2018 where I couldn't attend and then I actually attended in 2019
and as a result I was accepted as a member of the GA and for that I was very happy and very grateful
so yeah that's how I got involved in the FSC.
Wow that's quite a journey right?
Yeah and yeah since then being a member of the GA until this day basically until this year
Today we will also be talking about Free Software and Denmark so to have some bridge over to the topic
that we want to approach I was wondering how is the local group Arhus today?
I think you restarted meetings or?
Yeah and that happened after Covid and what happened after Covid or during Covid was two things
One thing was that a guy who really helped out with the Libra of Conference in 2015 like in 2021
he emailed me and asked them if I didn't feel like restarting some activities around Free Software
he said he would he was totally up for it if I wanted to restart some meetings and then I said yeah I might do that
and then another thing happened some months later which is that a guy which you know who is called Oivin called me out of the blue
and said that when looking for Free Software activities in Denmark he was like popping into my name all the time
and wouldn't I like to do something and then I said yeah well finally so I got in touch with the other guy
and paying some of the other people I knew from earlier and we restarted the meetings like in June 2022
Wow I didn't know that Oivin was around all this time
I'm very happy that he is because he's a co-editor of this podcast so yeah I'm very very happy about that
Yes but he was around since 2022
I should have a talk with him about that and figure this out
and ever since then you meet regularly and everybody's welcome to join
is it a local meeting in Oivis or is it an online meeting?
How can others participate if they are from Denmark and would like to do something for Free Software?
Well it is still a monthly meeting and originally at first we did all the meetings physically
but then there was a guy who was there at all the first meetings who said that
from a climate perspective and then ecological perspective he couldn't defend
going like 40 kilometers in a car every time he had to attend a meeting
why wouldn't we have online meetings sometimes?
So we shifted actually to online meetings
that was also because there were a lot of people who were from other parts of Denmark
especially Copenhagen who contacted us and said
why don't you do online meetings because we would also like to attend
How far is Copenhagen from Arhus?
350 kilometers
Oh wow
So it's quite some distance
it's not just for taking the car on the train
So yeah so actually we shifted our focus from local meetings in Arhus to online meetings for all of Denmark
and then we ideally want to do some physical activity every three months
and until this year we have kept it and some of these events have been related to other enseignments
and some have been related to the ILOV Free Software day
and some have been related to talks about digital sovereignty
but that is basically what we want to do
like meet up online every month but have some physical activity every three months
That sounds like an ambitious plan to be honest
How many people are there in the group currently?
It's difficult to say because it's not always the same people showing up
but I would say ten, twelve people who I would count
I think at our last online meeting we were six people
Yeah that sometimes this happens right
and especially in the summer
I can imagine that this is a bit of adult time
How do you manage that you organize something every three months in person?
This is quite a lot of work
Well it doesn't have to be all that work
We are fortunate enough that we have our collaborator, our member, our friend Espen
used to be very active in the IT workers union in Denmark called Posa
and as a result of their knowing him
he has simply obtained like a card plan for using Posa as a location for doing whatever
so we can use a meeting room to organize these public events
all we have to do is book it with them and then everything is clear-sailing
they are actually happy that we do that
because then they will announce it as an activity for their members
That's quite nice
Indeed it is
But you're really lucky in this regard that you have a dedicated IT union
because I can tell you in Germany this is not the case
we don't have a dedicated IT union
So that's quite cool that you have that
I gather from what you were saying that
you are basically really widespread
and that there are no other local groups in Denmark apart from the Aarhus local group
but the Aarhus local group is more a group for like everybody in Denmark
Yes, we widened our focus so to speak
I'm really I'm really happy that this worked out
and that you are able to do those online meetings
and that people actually join there and yeah that sounds really nice
Thank you so much for all the work you do in this regard cast
I'm happy to do it
This is a short break for our own cause
Thank you for listening to the Software Freedom Podcast
Working for Software Freedom and producing podcasts costs money
Please consider supporting us with a donation on the fsfe.org/donate and end the shownotes
There is also a lot of discussions going on in Denmark
as you probably know about Free Software and digital independence
Could you also take us through what the fsfe local group Aarhus is doing in this regard
and yeah basically what's the stand there and what's the discussion all about
Yes so very broad question I know
I know
As you probably know there has been some larger political issues or conflicts
I think many people in Denmark and also many politicians in Denmark
Many policy people in Denmark have had a very crude awakening with Donald Trump's threats
to simply take over Greenland in some form
because that was like completely unprecedented
Until now like the gospel in the public sector among politicians, among policy advisors
was all the time
You can trust the big American companies
because the US are our friends
They will always be our friends and just as the US government will always be our friends
so Microsoft will always be our friends
Apple will always be our friends maybe not Google
because there has been some skepticism towards Google
but that's quite a beside the point
but then all of a sudden this awakening
our former best friend is actually actively threatening us
and they can simply ask a huge company like Microsoft
they could simply ask them to turn off something like Office 365 in all of Denmark
and if they did that the entire Danish public sector would come to a complete stand still
so they had kind of a crude awakening and this has inspired a lot of discussion
a lot of interest around Free Software because there are these discussions
what is really needed to be in a situation where we are not dependent on what some foreign government is doing in that way
in our IT infrastructure
and we have been active in telling people that yeah
basically we have gone out with the message called public money, public code
and like it's not a question of not being European
it's not a question of not being American
it's a question of not being free
the problem is that the software needs to be Free Software
so people who use it can decide what it's going to do on their behalf
and that harkensberg actually to 2023
where we had a public meeting in a process meeting room
which was about saying goodbye to the tech giants
getting the tech giants out of our lives
and since all of this happened with the
since all of this happened with the Donald Trump situation
there has been a lot of interest in the public sector
and a lot of intents to really do something about it
and I know that in some ministries they are experimenting with facing in computers
with GNU Linux instead of Windows
they are experimenting with that kind of things in many places
I would say that in the public sector that is still not the will to start the kind of
investments that would really be needed to make a major transition to Free Software
and especially get away from something like the huge Microsoft monopoly
but there is definitely a lot of interest about it
and I can see that when we reach out to people like from the FSFE
I can see it in my day job and actually there was also last spring
this winter there was a lot of discussion about a new digital wallet
according to the new I think there is a directive from the EU
that says that people should have a digital wallet with a digital identity
and the EU directive explicitly states that this should be Free Software
and the Danish government at the time was creating a digital wallet
which they were actually doing as not Free Software
they were actually doing it as a closed source software
they were saying this is supposed to be as free as it can be
or as open source as it can be as they put it
but in the end that meant that the vendor was more or less at their
the vendor could more or less at their own discretion
make whatever they wanted of it closed and say
how we can't do this because we can only do this with the non-free libraries
but as a result of this there was a guy who joined forces with us
and we formulated some questions for the committee which was working on this in the parliament
so we sent these letters to the parliament
and a lot of other questions we organized like a campaign of questions
for this committee around why is this not 100% Free Software
how come this will not be available on any mobile phone
why is it only available on Google Android and Apple devices and so forth
and in the end it actually meant that this specific application has ended up being
much more free than it was originally
and it even can install on like alternative Android systems
oh like awesome ROMs?
yes yes yes exactly
but of course there are still some corners which are not of it which are not Free Software
unfortunately because it's relying on some Google libraries which are not Free Software
but with microG it will still run on custom ROMs so that is actually something
but what I really want to say here is that in the policy world, in the politics world
there is a lot of interest in the concepts of digital sovereignty
and there are lots of interest in the concepts of using Free Software
trying to be more independent of like big take
or be more independent of like proprietary third party dependencies
but there is very little understanding in mainstream politics
and policy environments about these issues
so yeah I would say we are in a position where what really needs to move forward
in Denmark in my opinion is what you could call education of the political classes
so they understand the issues at hand
I was not wondering I do have several questions and related that
but my first question dates back to the time frame
so when you mentioned that this basically all started with Donald Trump's second term
and the spoken of annexation of Greenland which has not yet happened
luckily I was wondering was there not something also going on after Edward Snowden
when it was publicly released that basically a lot of our data is collected
there was and actually I myself organized a crypto party at the central library in Arhus
in the wake of the Snowden revelations
so the Snowden revelations definitely sparked a lot of interest
but on the political level the interest didn't really take hold
because everybody in mainstream politics stocked through the memo about
or you would say stocked through the gospel about the US being our best friend
and if we don't have anything to hide then we don't have to worry and that kind of things
so the Danish politicians have when they have been in government generally been very pro surveillance
okay so it did not spark the same conversation as it has sparked now with the second term of Donald Trump
no mostly in community this Snowden revelations mostly had impact in the population in communities
not really at the political level in the same way
and you also mentioned that there is some lack in understanding or following through
not understanding probably but following through with Free Software in all regards
I was wondering like are you as a local group doing something about this
and do you have meetings in this regard, do you have events in this regard
to also talk with others about this and to do some outreach?
Yes as you have heard about we are actually as a group in a dialogue with Johannes
and Alex from the FZV organization about organizing an event with a headline of public money, public code
whose target audience will be people from the public administrations
and this event was originally scheduled to be in September
but it turned out that there are some, there is another important municipal meetings around IT
at the same date as we had a regular chosen
so right now in Denmark and for that reason we have had to move it to a present
we are looking at March and the venue we want to use is an auditorium in the main library in Ols
and we will book it as soon as we can but they don't open the booking for that season until September
so as soon as we can we will book the venue and then we will fix a date probably in March
probably around 9, 10, 11th March if I remember correctly
and then we will have this meeting like a one day conference centered on public money, public code
where we will invite decision makers, IT versus IT workers
from the public sector to come and discuss share their experiences
and we will also try to gently direct the conversation in the duration of focusing on Free Software
and not just non-American software
that sounds really good and it sounds like a lot of work
yeah probably probably
you said that politicians will be the intercession makers are the main target group
and that you will invite them but is everybody else also invited to join or will it be a closed event
do you already know that?
now in order for us to use that venue the event has to be open for everybody in all whose was interested
because it's in the library
so but we will only invite decision makers from the municipalities
but everybody who is interested can show up and hear what we are discussing
that sounds really cool
thank you so much for taking me through this
it has been an increase in people showing up after the discussion about digital
independence and Free Software started in Denmark
and has this been like a topic that people bring along to your group
even if they are from the outside
or even if they have not been involved formally in the FSFIs local group in our house
yes it's definitely a thing that people are very interested in
and that is definitely also something that I think we can contribute with
how can people start building like their own infrastructure and not be dependent on the tech giants
now if you will permit me to expand a bit
of course I and OEVN have been very fond of using an operating system based on Debian
which is called YUNOhost
like spelled UNOhost
which is a system that you can put on a virtual server
you can put it on a physical server
and it permits you to install a lot of services
and run them yourself without actually knowing how to set them up
because it will set it up for you
so I am running my own version of Cast2Port
which is podcasting software
I am running that on my own server
I am running my own Synapse and Element
to do matrix communication
I used to run my own method on server
but that was a bit too heavy
and if I wanted to take out the time
I could run my own mail server there
so you can actually be very non-technical
and still do a lot towards simply building your own infrastructure
instead of depending on the tech giants
and that is something people have been very interested in talking to us about
all right
that's basically so there are more interested also in their way of
being digital to run by themselves
exactly
I like that
thank you so much
and yeah I was also wondering last but not least
what can other people in Denmark do?
can they join you?
how can they join you?
that is currently happening because the PMPC event
apparently is still some months away
but in the meantime
what can people interested in Free Software do to help you?
well
if they want to reach out
they can reach out to me
the Denmark coordinator
or to Øjvind, the deputy coordinator,
and
they can search for my name
and find my email address
but we also
actually have a
we also actually have a matrix group
FSFE DK
which should be easy to find
if you are on matrix
and if you are not on matrix
we have a mailing list
which is arhus at lists.fse.org
but if you go through lists.fse.org
you can search for arhus
and then you can join the mailing list
and then you are very welcome to reach out to us
and propose anything you want
and the monthly meetings are always announced
on the mailing list
and on the matrix group
okay
anything you want to add?
anything that is left from your site?
yes
that in discussions about digital sovereignty in Denmark
we often meet the opinion
in other groups working with this topic
that it's about having European solutions
not about necessarily having Free Software solutions
so I have people telling me that
I should ditch Firefox
because it's American
and then I should use the Vivaldi browser instead
and then I point it out to them
that the Vivaldi browser is actually proprietary firstly
and secondly it's built on Chromium
which is just as American and Firefox
and thirdly
Firefox is actually Free Software
and there are a lot of derivatives
you can use instead
like LibraWolf or whatever
so the distinction between European
and American doesn't really make sense
what makes sense is the distinction between free and proprietary
the same way people are telling me that
if I don't want to use the American proprietary
artificial intelligent robots
like those from OpenAI
or Anthropic
I should use something like mistrial instead
because it's French and it's European
but then I also need to point out
that that's still proprietary
and they are still not disclosing
which data they have been training their models on
so it's actually even though it's European
it's just as bad
some big proprietary European product
is not better for being European
it is better for being Free Software
and if it's Free Software
and that is something which really needs to be communicated
and exactly communicating that kind of understanding
is what I would like to do
with our work in our group in Denmark
oh that's very cool
and nicely fits in in our communication
as FSFE
because we also communicate
that by European
it's not the solution to digital sovereignty
and digital sovereignty can only be achieved
as you said through Free Software
and I think you really
neatly outlined why this is the case
and yeah, I just thank you very much
so I'm very curious to see how you will
how this will all come along
especially with the PMPC event in Denmark
yeah, thank you so much for taking the time
to walk me through what's happening in Denmark currently
and also what will be the next steps there
thank you so much
you're welcome, I was happy to be here
alright, this was the software freedom podcast
if you liked this episode
please recommend it to your friends and rate it
stay tuned for more inspiring conversations
that explore the importance of software freedom
and its impact on our digital lives
this podcast is presented to you
by the Free Software Foundation Europe
we are a charity that works on promoting software freedom
if you like our work
please consider supporting us with our donation
you find more information
under fsfe.org slash donate
thank you so much for listening
and yeah, supporting the software freedom podcast
bye bye
you